[Music]
farcry new dawn is finally here and
sinlessly other games from the franchise
there's a lot to embattlement the
standalone expansion serves as a
narrative continuation of Far Cry 5 with
the world still coming to grips with the
nuclear attack known as the collapse the
devastating conclusion to Far Cry 5 has
completely rocked the landscape of Hope
County and new dawn follows the tales of
the survivors of this hellish world the
game itself possesses two endings that
build on the law and bring the
character's story to a somewhat
satisfying conclusion but how do you
obtain these endings and what actually
happens in there well throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the two
final cutscenes of the game as well as
how to get there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't completed far
crying you dawn and don't want to know
either ending and I highly suggest that
you turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I play it so you don't
have to Far Cry new dawn has both a good
and bad ending and both alter the game
in pre-major ways the ending you get
boils down to the simple choice of
whether to kill Mickey and Joseph or to
let them live firstly Mickey promises
that if you spare her life that you'll
never see her again this is a difficult
one as she's been pretty ruthless about
killing people throughout the game but
on the other hand she seems to have
finally realized the error of her ways
and the character looks like she wants
to change the second choice comes with
whether to kill or spare Joseph similar
to Mickey he comes to the realization I
had caused a lot of death and suffering
in the name of God the character begs
you to kill him even putting your gun to
his chest while it's pleading that you
give him a one-way ticket to the
afterlife what you choose to do here
impacts the ending in several ways which
I'll now break down starting with what
happens if you kill the characters
if you decide to kill Mickey and Joseph
and hey who could blame you the game
ends with Carmina and you sharing a beer
by Russia's grave you can go visit where
you murdered the characters and nothing
is there so you don't have to worry
about any highwaymen or new eden
worshipers who are out for revenge all
in all this is classed as the bad ending
that most players will get on that first
run-through of the game as the two
characters are probably too dangerous to
leave out in the world even if it is a
bit of a crap hole so if you do the
opposite and spare them what happens
then well if you decide to spare the two
you still get the same seen how Russia's
grave but you actually get rewarded for
being the bigger person when you go back
to visit where you last left Mickey it
seems that the character has been true
to her word and has stuck to the promise
that she gave you on a rock beside where
you had the choice to kill her you will
find a helmet with an O that reads it
deals a deal rabbit I'm out you'll still
have some Highwaymen to deal with they
won't want to give up the good life
they've got here but that's your problem
to solve me I'm gonna head back east and
look for my mom a long time ago or dad
made us leave her behind I'm gonna go
see if he's still alive out there it's a
long shot but it's all I've got left so
it seems like Mickey is finally on a
righteous path as it were and she's
trying to mend her ways a lot of fans
have theorized that the next Far Cry
game may even feature Mickey as the main
character and you'll be able to see
things from her point of view this would
give you the option to either go good or
bad depending on whether you want to
stick to your word or not and it would
give the players a lot to look forward
to she's definitely an interesting
person so I as I'm sure you would love
to see things from her point of view but
don't think that it ends there Josef is
still out there to remember and if you
return to the place where you spared him
you'll get the complete opposite to
Mickey there's no no nobody and no sign
that he has really done anything of
course after he begged for you to kill
him leaving him alive is a bigger
but I'd imagine that if they do go the
secret route with Mickey that we once
again find him as the main antagonist
devising devious plans for the future
based on how he can bring the Word of
God to the people in the most brutal way
overall that's the conclusion of the two
choices and I do think the latter is
definitely teasing towards a sequel
which you hope to get at some point in
the near future so what were your
thoughts on the ending of far cry new
dawn and which one did you pick comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of the ending of
Kingdom Hearts which will be linked
after this video this is the channel for
the hardcore players so if that's the
kinda thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again to take the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you